so much of acting is like not getting
intimidated right
that's like that's 99 of it oh my god if
you had to work with a big actor
you know you'd be [ __ ] bricks
because you think if you messed up they
were just gonna crucify you
right so i got past that movie and the
movie made a lot of money
and then you get the movie ricochet with
uh denzel washington right
yeah and that was weird because i met
joel silver
and joel he's a big producer the biggest
the biggest
matrix you know predator and i walked
into his office and i said to him
okay i'm oh howard first movie i made
twenty six thousand dollars for new
jersey
for new jack city right in a movie made
87 million
and when it makes 87 million you
probably think hey i should get my quota
no
i got i got scale and that's called
paying dues
right so i went into joel silver's
office like yo i know i'm about to get
paid
now [ __ ] i'm about to joel silva
you know what joe silva told me
what he said iced tea you've done one
movie
no one's looking for you and so i got
i got i got like 46 000 for less work
but i'm moving up yeah and uh i didn't
get any money my first real check was
tank girl with lori petty playing a
[ __ ] kangaroo
is that right what'd you get for that a
million dollars no
kidding yeah i'll play a goddamn
kangaroo for half a million you damn
skippy i was i was doing a movie with
keanu reeves called
johnny mnemonic and they called me and
they said would you play a stripper in
arizona and i'm like [ __ ] yeah i'll play
a stripper
i did like a thousand sit-ups that night
i'm like i'm ready for this then the
next day they sent me a picture of a
kangaroo
yeah and i'm like what the [ __ ] and then
they go
it's called tank girl i'm like that's
just so generic i'm like i'm
am i not with [ __ ] keanu reeves up
and what the [ __ ] are we going backwards
do i owe money what's happening
and then they go they're going to pay
you this much and i started like hopping
around the room like a [ __ ] club
are you kidding like you kidding me yeah
so that was my first
check oh my god that's unbelievable